the U.N now describes Afghanistan's
hunger crisis as pure catastrophe some
25 million Afghans live in poverty food
prices are soaring and officials are
worried that many malnourished children
will not survive the upcoming winter MTS
tayev has seen the unfolding tragedy
firsthand he joins us from Kabul
Afghanistan's Capital
MTS good morning
Nate good morning to you well
Afghanistan is really in the grips of
what the U.N is calling the world's
worst humanitarian crisis with 90
percent of people here going hungry a
warning now some of the images in this
report may be distressing to watch
Afghanistan is starving
and these babies are among the most
malnourished
at kabul's Indira Gandhi Children's
Hospital infants from across the country
are brought here for specialized
treatment
this mother tells us her four-month-old
son Murtaza weighs just six and a half
pounds your son is so small so frail you
must be very worried about him
yes we are so worried she says she lost
one son already and fears she will lose
him too
hunger has long plagued Afghanistan but
since the talibans take over one year
ago the Biden Administration froze
billions in State Bank assets
and international donors hold financial
support
the doctors here say it's people who are
paying the price
[Music]
one or two malnourished children die
here every day he says
you lose one or two children a day yes
unfortunately
in the taliban's Afghanistan hunger
stocks nearly every street the number of
people waiting outside of bakeries
hoping for a handout of bread is only
growing each loaf costs just 11 cents
but even that's too expensive for
najibola who works as a day laborer
lately work has been hard to come by the
Taliban have been in power for a year
now are they helping you
I haven't received a penny from one of
them
so life is worse for you under the
Taliban
yes it's terrible it's a slow death for
us life is not worth living where
there's no food and no work
as the sun sets a local resident offers
to buy bread for the dozens of men and
women who have been waiting outside the
bakery
the total cost isn't more than a few
dollars but for everyone here it means
they and their families won't go to bed
hungry at least
tonight
now Aid is trickling into Afghanistan
but it's just not enough to solve this
humanitarian catastrophe Tony
MTS tayab live from Afghanistan a
country where some hospitals are losing
one child a day to hunger it's a story
will stay on MTS thank you very much